[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف لها نغم يحس به
الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
ما اسرع الايام في طينه تمضي علينا ثم
تمضي بنا السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
يقول الله تعالى فانما هي زجره واحده فاذا
هم بالساهره الزجره الصيحه وقيل الصياح
المصحوب بالغضب فانما هي صيحه واحده ونفخه
تنفخ في الصور تقول زجر فلان فلانا اذا
امره او نهاه عن شيء بحده وغضب وجاء في
بعض قصائد نابغه قوله وتعجبني اللذات ثم
يعوجني ويستغني عنها من الله ساتر
ويسجرني للاسلام والشيب والتقى وفي الشيب
والاسلام للمرء زاجر
ما اجمل هذا البيت ويسجرني الاسلام والشيب
والتقى وفي الشيب والاسلام للمرء زاجر
فاذا هم بالساهره العرب تسمي الفلاته ووجه
الارض ساهره قال ابن عباس وغيره الساهره
الارض وقيل هي الارض المستويه وكثره
الاقوال في سبب تسميتها فقيل انما سميت
بذلك لان فيها نوم الحيوان وسهرها وقيل
لان عملها في النبت دائما ليلا ونهارا
ولذلك يقال خير المال عين خراره في ارض
خواره تسهر اذا نمت وتشهد اذا غبت
وقال اميه بن ابي السلط وفيها لحم ساهره
وبحر وما فاهوا بهم لهم مقيموا
وقال ابو ذئيب يرتدن ساهره كان عميمها
وجميمها اسداف ليلا مظلمي وقيل لان السراب
يجري فيها من قولهم عين ساهره جاريه الماء
قال الاشعث ابن قيس وساهره يضحي السراب
مجللا لاقطارها قد جبتها متلثما ثم صارت
الساهره اسما لكل ارض
[موسيقى]
احدثكم عن غزوه تسمى غزاه المصيبه كانت
سنه
339 حين امعن سيف الدوله في النكايه بعدوه
وخلال عودته منتصرا
اسرع امام معظم جيشه فلما راه خصمه اللدود
ادمسدق والدمستق هي تسميه لرتبه عسكريه في
جيش بيزنطه راه الدمستق في كوكبه قليله
فهاجم اوائل فرسانه وكانت دمستق في الوف
من الجيش
فتراجع فرسان سيف الدوله وهزم بعضهم ثم
اشرف عليهم سيف الدوله اشرف على جيش
بيزنطه فاستبسل حتى فرد مصدق
وقتل كثيرا من فرسانه واسر من بطارقته نيف
وثمانون فخلد المتنبي ابداع الفعل بابداع
القول يقول
تمشي الكرام على اثار غيرهم وانت تخلق ما
تاتي وتبتدع من كان فوق محل الشمس موضعه
فليس يرفعه شيء ولا يضع
وقد المح الى هذه المفارقه البديعه بقوله
بالجيش يمتنع السادات كلهم
والجيش بابن ابي الهجاء يمتنع
وفي سياق تصوير المتنبي لسيف الدوله
باعتباره مفردا بصيغه الجمه وانه هو جيش
الجيش
نستحضروا قوله في قصيده الحدث الحمراء
يكلف سيف الدوله للجيش همه وقد عجزت عنه
الجيوش الخضارم ويطلب عند الناس ما عند
نفسه وذلك ما لا تدعيه الضراغب
وخلاصه فلسفه المتنبي في فراده ممدوعه
الجدير بفراده مدائحه قوله على قدر اهل
العزم تاتي العزائم وتاتي على قدر الكرام
المكارم وتكبر في عين الصغير صغارها وتصغر
في عين العظيم العظائم
[موسيقى]
الاعرابي اذا قيل له يا عربي فرح بذلك وهش
والعربي اذا قيل له يا اعرابي غضب فمن نزل
الباديه اوجها وراء البادين فضعن بضعنهم
وانتوى بانتوائهم فهم اعراب ومن نزل بلاد
الريش واستوطن المدن والقرى العربيه
وغيرها مما ينتمي الى العرب فهم عرب وان
لم يكونوا فصحاء
وقد قال القديم حسن الحضاره مجلوب بتطريه
وفي البداوه حسن غير مجلوب
[موسيقى]
جاء في الاثر
رحم الله امرا اصلح من لسانه وكان ابن عمر
يضرب ولده على اللحن وكان ايوب ستياني اذا
لحن استغفر الله وكان يونس بن حبيب يقول
ليس للاحن مروءه ولا لتارك الاعراب بها
كانوا في السابق يجلون الرجل لفصاحته
وربما قدموه في المجالس حتى في مجالس اهل
الحل والعقد يحكى ان رجلين كان يلعبان
الشطرنج فدخل رجل
فالطياه رقعه الشطرنج احتراما له
ومخافه ان تسقط مروءتهما اذ يلعبان امامه
فلما نطق لحن اي اخطا في الاعراب فما كان
منهما الا ان فتحا رقعه الشطرنج واستانفاه
اللعب وقالا ليس للحنا حرما يعني ليس لك
ما فعلناه من اجلك من مراسم الاحترام
والتوقير وهذا جدير بنا اليوم يعني لا
ينبغي للمرء ان يكون كثيرا اللحن فيما
يقول وفيما يكتب
الاخطاء الشائعه قد تكون في المعنى
المعجمي الدلالي وقد تكون في التركيب
الاسلوبي وقد تكون في البنيه الصرفيه
البضاعه المباعه صوابها البضاعه المبيعة
حسب ما يقتضيه القياس الصرفي
ونضوج الفاكهه
ونحوها صوابها الصرفي النضج لنضج
[موسيقى]
ينهى بعض المفتين المتشددين عن مناداه
الابوين بابا وماما زاعلين ان اللفظين
اعجميان والحقيقه ان نداء بابا وماما فطره
لغويه انسانيه ففي الحال الكبير في فقه
الشافعي للمورد
اول ما يظهر من الطفل حرف الحلق في البكاء
ثم حروف الشفا في بابا وماما ثم حروف
اللسان اذا تكلم وبعض ذلك يتلو بعضا بل ان
هذا النداء عربي اصيل جاء في نوادر اللغه
لابي زيد الانصاري وقال العنبريون بابا
الصبي اباه
وباباه ابوه اذا قال له يا بابا
وماما الصبي امه فهو يمئها
وقد قال العباس ابن الاحنف لها لعب مصففه
تلقبهن القابا تنادي كلما ريعت من الغره
يا بابا
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل يحمل شن ويفدى لكيز فما قصه
المثل
قصته ان اخوين يسميان شنا ولوكيزا سافرا
مع امهما فنزلوا بموضع فلما هموا بالرحيل
فدت ولدها المدلل لكيزا بكل غال لديها
ودعت اخاه شندا ليتولى حملها ففعل ذلك وهو
غضبان حتى اذا توسطوا ثنيه بالطريق رمى
بها عن بعيرها وقال يحمل شن ويفدى لكيز
فاصبحت مثلا يضرب في وضع الشيء في غير
موضعه
وربما ضربوه في الرجلين يهان احدهما ويكرم
الاخر واذا تكون كريهه ادعى لها واذا يحاس
الحيث يدعى جده
[موسيقى]
هذه المره لم اضع لكم الوسم وانما وجدت
صديقي محمد عبد العزيز قد كتب في تويتر
مثلا شعبيا عشمتني بالحلق خرمتنا وداني
فالحلق طبعا هو الحلق الذي يوضع في الاذن
وكالعاده اهلنا في مصر وفي الشام يضعون
همزه مكان القاف
فصديقي مثلا يريد ان يقول انه قلق
فبدل ان يقول قلق او قلقان يقول الان
فاقول له الان ولا بعد قليل فيستشيط غضبا
لانه لا يحب النكت البايخه كما يسميها على
كل حال انا سالتكم في تويتر ما هي او ماذا
يشابه هذا المثل في لهجاتكم المثل اللي هو
عشمتني بالحلق خرمتنا وداني
فاستعرض معكم فيما يلي بعض المشاركات
هنا مشاركه من بيان تقول لم اتذكر مثلا
شعبيا لكن تذكرت بيت شعر يقول وما فئه
الاصلاح الا كبارق يغرك بالقطر الذي ليس
يهطل وهذا قريب من المعنى ايناس تقول
كثيرا تذكرت لم اجد في لهجتنا ما يحاكيه
ولكن بالنسبه للمثل يقال للذي عشم ان
سحائب وعدك قد ابرقت فليكن وابلها سالما
من علل المطل
مشاركه من عيسى المناعي يقول سخنا الماي
وطار الديك
الديك يعني
يعني تعشبنا انه في حاجه نطبخها يعني ولكن
ما عاد فيه وهذا يعني نفس نفس المعنى ايضا
زبيده تقول رصابه اللسان رطابه اللسان
وقله الادام
اتوقع انه ربابه اللسان يعني انه تلممض
الانسان لما يشعر انه في طعام ولكن قله
الادامه اتوقع الادام يعني الايدام
بنفس بنفس ما يوافق هذا ايضا المعنى اسماء
تقول حضر الرسم قبل الجمل
اولا يا اسماء الرسم ليس للابل
وثانيا لا ارى انه يعني المعنى يقع على
المعنى ولكن شكرا لك على كل حال
محمد يقول باللهجه الحسانيه شاف النو وفلت
قربه او قربه
القرب التي معه يعني
اي انه راى البرق
فاثلى ما بين يديه من قرب الماء طمعا
بالمطر
وهذا ايضا قريب والنوب المناسبه مفرده
فصيحه
ما زالت مستخدمه الى الان في الدارج
الخليجيه في شبه الجزيره العربيه
مشاركه اخيره من شهر يقول وصلتنا بنص
البير وقطعت الحبل فينا
يعني
المثل الاول ما فيه وصول ويمكن العشم هو
كان وصول الى منتصف البئر يعني ممكن يكون
المعنى قريبا شكرا لك يا شهر على كل حال
وشكرا لكم جميعا على هذه
المشاركات الجميله هذه اول مره اضع لكم
وسما من اختيار غيري الصديق محمد عبد
العزيز لكن ممكن يعني تعتمد هذه الطريقه
احيانا اذا كان هناك ما يستدعي لا تنسوا
اسم تاملات الجزيره
[موسيقى]
امام جليل لا يختلف اثنان على تقواه وصبره
وزهده لكنه خلف اتباعا تشدد بعضهم فاسرف
واعتدل بعضهم فتعايش
احمد بن حنبل كان ذا شخصيه جذبت الناس
اليه في حياته وجذبتهم الى مذهبه بعد موته
شخصيه تقوم على الزهد والصبر والتمسك
بالمعتقد كان يعيش على كراء دكانين خلفه
ماله ابوه وكان يعتاش ايضا بالتقاط الثمر
اجيرا عند المزارعين ابن حنبل شيباني عربي
بغدادي وهو المحدث صاحب المسند المشهور
في زمن المامون ثم المعتصم وقف في وجه
المعتزله وعارضهم في مساله خلق القران
الكريم
فامتحن وتمسك بقوله وضرب وسجينا سنتين
واشهرا زاره عمه اسحاق في سجنه فقال لعمه
لست ابالي السجن فهو مثل بيتي ولا ابالي
السيف انما اخاف خفقه بالسوط لا اصبر لها
فسمعه احد من بالسجن فقال له ما هو الا
سوطان ثم انك لا تدري اين يقع الباقي
فسري عنه وجاءه بعض من محبيه في سجنه بماء
مثلوج فسال انال كل من بالسجن هذا الماء
قيل لا فابى ان يشربه
مات المعتصم وتولى الخلافه الواثق التي
استمر في مناصره المعتزله غير انه اخرج
ابن حنبل من السجن وارسل اليه الا تساكنني
في بلد فتشرد ابن حنبل في البلاد ثم عاد
الى بيته متواريا لا يخرج حتى مات الواثق
وتولى المتوكل الخلافه فرفع المحنه عن اهل
السنه واحسن الى ابن حنبل
مدح احدهم ابن حنبل بصبره وثباته فقال له
ابن حنبل من ذلك اخي احمد بن نصر الخزاعي
اغلظوا له القول فاغلى لهم وما خافهم
فضربوا عنقه
عاش ابن حنبل بعد رفع المحنه اثنتين
وعشرين سنه كان يخرج من الصلاه فيتبعوه
الناس فيقف حتى ينصرفوا ثم يسير وحده الى
بيته وكان صديقا للامام الشافعي
قالوا يزورك احمد وتزوره قلت الفضائل لا
تفارق منزله ان زارني فبفضله او زرته
فلفظله والفضل في الحالين له ومهما طلب
الامام احمد الخمول راضيا بالاشتغال بجمع
الحديث كان يزداد تعلق الناس به قيل له
مره ان اهل البدع قد كثروا فقال بيننا
وبينهم الجنائز ومات احمد بن حنبل عن سبع
وسبعين سنه
يقول ابن كثير ما اجتمع خلق في جاهليه او
في اسلام مثل ما اجتمع في جنازه احمد بن
حنبل
كان ابن حنبل سريع العفو عمن اساء اليه
بلغه في سجنه ان المعتصم فتح عموريه
فسامحه ودعا له على ان حنابله بغداد
اسرفوا في التشدد بعد موت امامهم فاعتدوا
على المخالفين وارهبوهم واتكى على مذهب
ابن حنبل اخرون لم يكونوا في مثل تسامح
صاحب المذهب عليه رحمه الله
بيننا وبينهم الجنائز
[موسيقى]
كانت الشمس نازله في طريق هذا الغروب وكنت
واقفا امام الجدار فرايت ظلي وظل النخله
وظل الجدار والاعمده التي عليه
فقلت في ذلك
ظلي
وظل النخل والاطوال
سجدت لرب واحد
متعالي
سجدت له عند الغدو مطيعه
ومطيعه سجدت لدى الاعصار يا من له وعنه
الوجوه تولني واضلني اذ لا تحين ظلال
بالفضل لا بالعدل عاملني اذا ما ساء في
يوم التغابن حالي فخر المفاخر انني لك
مسلم ولقد مننت به بغير سؤالي فاجب دعائي
اذ سالتك جنه ليست تبلغني لها اعمالي
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]